direction versailles à présent où l'un
des plus grand musée de l'histoire de
france vient de rouvrir certaines de ces
fall le site
le château et ses galeries où désormais
plus de mille cinq cents oeuvres sont
présentées au public sur 5000 mètres
carrés et des oeuvres qui raconte
l'histoire de france dont l'accession au
pouvoir de louis philippe qui fut à
l'origine de ce musée visite guidée avec
karine shana et marque doux 10 juin 10
837 derrière ses fenêtres du château de
versailles c'est l'effervescence
devant des centaines d'invités le roi
louis-philippe inaugure son musée
d'histoire dédié à toutes les gloires de
france un musée enrichi depuis dont
certains installent totalement ou
partiellement fermés faute d'agents de
surveillance hors ouvre aujourd'hui et
comme un immense livre ouvert dans la
galerie des batailles ce sont les plus
grandes victoires de l'histoire de
france qui sont illustrés entre tolbiac
et wagram des oeuvres signées horace
vernet ou encore à de la fois
immortalise enfin le week en pleine
bataille de taillebourg
autre porte d'entrée sol histoire dans
cette salle le décor est résolument
néogothique les oeuvres elles racontent
les croisades
mais pour louis philippe la vocation de
ce musée est aussi politique
il avait besoin de rallier à sa
politique à sa personne tous les partis
politiques de l'époque des légitimistes
au bonapartiste aux républicains et
jusqu'aux orléaniste effet son propre
parti
et
les orléanistes la révolution de 1830
qui l'a porté au pouvoir
louiseville encore est consacré toute
une salle et avec celle illustrant le
règne de louis xiv
c'est près d'un tiers de ce musée qui
dévoile aujourd'hui ses trésors musée
qui à l'époque sauva le château de la
ruine